operation shadow legacy begins soon in
rainbow six siege
and it's bringing splinter cell sam
fisher into the fold
here's everything you need to know about
the new operator
sam fisher's rainbow six code name is
zero and as you'd probably expect
he's an attacker armed with an sc3000
assault rifle
mp7 and 5.7 usg he can also carry either
frag grenades or a claymore as his
secondary gadget
but what you really want to know about
is his operator gadget
the argus launcher this launches cameras
that can pierce through breakable and
reinforced surfaces
once the camera is mounted sam can
toggle it to look through either side of
the wall
the camera can also fire a single laser
shot which is powerful enough to destroy
operator gadgets
like alibi's prisma decoy
other players can mess with your camera
though it can be destroyed and mute can
jam it with his signal disrupters for
example
so as with any operator there's a give
and take with sam's special
ability he's the biggest addition to
siege in operation shadow legacy but
he's not the only change coming
defenders will be able to place more
reinforcements now
each player can place up to 4 walls from
a total pool of 10.
some attacking operators will also get a
new secondary gadget
the hard breaching round which can make
holes in reinforced walls
meanwhile thatcher is getting nerfed
specifically his emp
grenades will now only be able to
disable gadgets instead of destroying
them
lastly the chalet map is getting a
rework that sees many of its familiar
areas
changed so that's a whole lot of shake
up for the meta for the new season
and that's all you need to know before
you jump in stay tuned to gamespot for
more coverage of the new siege season
[Music]
you